[Music]
the targaryen civil war the divided
targaryen dynasty and the entire west
rose in two
is the main event of house of the dragon
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
it's based on georgia martin's book fire
and blood vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1
ended with rhaenyra targaryen's son
aegon iii
reign and will cover blackfyre
rebellions the war with dorne and go all
the way to the mad king
and robert's rebellion that attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the prequel will be the
dance of the dragon
a targaryen civil war it was a war of
succession
between rhaenyra and her blacks and
aegon and his greens
the blacks previously known as the party
of the princess
were the faction of house targaryen and
their loyalists who supported the ascent
of rhaenyra targaryen as queen of the
seven kingdoms
during the dance of the dragons and the
years that preceded it
they were opposed by the greens the
title derives from a great tournament
held in 111ac at king's landing
on the fifth anniversary of king vista
is the first marriage to queen ellis and
hightower
his second wife at the opening feast
queen alice sent war a green gown
while princess rhaenyra targaryen
wizards daughter by his first wife
dressed dramatically in targaryen red
and black note was
taken and thereafter it became the
custom to refer to greens and blacks
when talking of the queen's party and
the party of the princess
generally rhaenyra was supported by
noble families who had enjoyed royal
favor during her father's reign
and possessed strong ties to the crown
while legend ii
rallied those who had been out of favor
viserys the first had signed charters
with many powerful houses
in which they soared to accept rhaenyra
as his heir
but at least some of them broke their
word after viserys died
obviously the most prominent of the
blacks is its leader and the person they
were all fighting for
rhaenyra targaryen princess rhaenyra
targaryen cheered as the realms delight
when she was young
and later called the half-year queen was
the first born
child of king viserys the first
targaryen reiner was king viserys is the
first
only living child by his first wife
queen emma of house serena
at the age of eight she was made her
father's heir and grew up expecting to
become the first ruling queen of
westeros
reiner was a dragon rider whose mount
was cyrex
rhaenyra had her family's valyrian looks
varying her silver gold hair in a long
braid in the manner of queen visenya
targaryen
beautiful as a child rhaenyra was later
declared by her uncle prince daemon
targaryen to be the most beautiful
maiden
in all the seven kingdoms due to the
lack of a male heir viserys designated
rhaenyra as his successor
therefore rhaenyra was the only female
targaryen to lay claim to the iron
throne in her
own right after rhaenyra's mother died
her father remarried
and had several sons with his second
wife alicent of house hightower
even so viserys still publicly expected
his daughter to succeed him
and when he died his official will even
stated so
however rhaenyra's younger half-brother
aegon challenged her claim
he stated that the normal inheritance
laws of the andals
which formed the basis of the unified
law code in westeros
called for male preference primogeniture
meaning that a younger son would
rightfully inherit before
an older daughter at the time of her
father's death
rhaenyra was done dragonstone evading
the birth of her child
the green sinking's landing ensured that
the news of viserys's death did not
reach her until her own supporters in
the red keep were dead
or imprisoned and aegon the second's
coronation had already occurred
this began a devastating civil war that
tore apart the seven kingdoms
known as the dance of the dragons as it
was the only war in which both sides had
dragon riders
the war lasted for three years and by
the time it came to an end
nearly all of the targaryen dragons had
been killed the conflict also resulted
in the death of three of rhaenyra's five
sons
as well as the eldest son of fagon the
second rhaenyra's personal sigil was the
normal targaryen heraldry
a three-headed red dragon and a black
field quartered with the moon and falcon
sigil of house serene
for her mother emmarin and the silver
seahorse on sea green of house valerian
for her first husband lana valerian as
well as for the valerians in general
who were among her major supporters
during the dance her faction used her
personal heraldry as her battle flag
while both sides lost much and more in
the war it's a fact that the blacks won
the war
and it's a fact that rhaenyra even
though dead by the end of it
also won the war because it's her sons
that got the throne and not aegons
and the targaryen line continued through
her meaning that present time targaryens
are descendants of rhaenyra
and not of her half-brother aegon the
next most prominent of the blacks is the
character that did the most in this war
the character that is equally loved and
hated in westeros
and the black's best warrior general and
commander the rogue prince daemon
targaryen
damon targaryen also known as prince of
the city lord flee bottom and the rogue
prince had many titles throughout his
life
prince sir commander of the city watch
master of coin master of loss
king of the stepstones and the narrow
sea protector of the realm
daemon was the most controversial man of
his lifetime
an audacious rogue prince and adventurer
who seemed made of good and evil in
equal measure
there was never a man so loved and so
reviled and at the same time as he was
during the dance of the dragons as the
husband of his niece rhaenyra he
supported his wife's claim
and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in westeros
he was rhaenyra's second husband
following sir leonard valorian
and she was his third wife prince damon
was the most experienced warrior of his
time
and wielded the valyrian steel blade
dark sister a dragon rider whose dragon
was characters
daemon declared himself the king of the
stepstones and the narrow sea
after giving his two daughters daemon's
second wife lena died in 120 ac
trying to birth him a son who died as
well in 120 ac
daemon married again this time to his
niece princess rhaenyra targaryen
this marriage was performed suddenly
without the knowledge of king viserys
the first targaryen
and was scandalous since neither elena
nor lane or valerian
damon's previous wife and rhaenyra's
previous husband had been dead for six
months
according to mushroom it was damon who
arranged the death of lenore
by paying sir corey to kill him thus
making rhaenyra available to mary
damon and rhaenyra had two sons together
prince saigon the younger born in 120 ac
and prince viserys born in 122 ac
at the start of the civil war called the
dance of the dragons prince daemon had
more experience in warfare
then all their foes combined during
rhaenyra's rival coronation on
dragonstone daemon plays the crown of
king jaehaerys first targaryen on the
head of his wife
proclaiming her the queen and claiming
himself the protector of the realm
daemon led the assault on harrenhal
capturing the ruined castle from its
castellan
after hearing of the death of his
stepson prince lucerus velaryon at the
hands of his nephew
prince eamonn targaryen daemon through
his spymaster and former mistress
miseria
hired blood and cheese to kill a son of
fake on the second
son for a son damon abandoned harrenhal
when eamon and kristen begin marching
on the great castle with a host of
greens instead daemon flew characters
back to king's landing
and assisted rhaenyra with capturing the
city he made his niece and wife rhaenyra
the queen of the seven kingdoms
his next and final act in the war and in
his life was the battle above the god's
eye
when he challenged king aegon's brother
and the most prominent of the greens
aemond one eye which is the day both the
blacks and the greens lost its best
warriors and commanders
eamonn answered the demon's challenge
arrived on legendary dragon bogar
and the most epic battle of the entire
war was about to start
when he climbed upon characters daemon
did not fast in his chains that
connected him
since daemon's dragon was a lot younger
and smaller than aemons
daemon was quickly hidden in clouds
while eamonn looked for him
when characters attacked vegar she
ripped up on his stomach and tore one of
his wings
but then characters fast and his jaws
surround her throat in death grip
these injuries forced them both to cease
flying
and as they tumbled through the water
below daemond dueled eamonn to death
as he never fastened his settle daemon
stood up on charaxes
and lapped at aymond whereupon he drove
his dark sister
through eamonn's eye and through his
neck just a second before hitting the
water
the battle above the god's eye ended in
the deaths of both riders
and both the dragons daemon was 49 when
he died
unlike eamonn's body however demons was
never found
singers say that daemon lived to spend
the rest of his days in secret with
nettles
but most historians disagree house of
the dragon will end this debate between
singers and historians
and reveal why daemon's body was never
found and did he really survive
and live his days out in peace with
nettles the next prominent member of the
blacks was lord stark
craig stark known as the old man of the
north the wolf of the north and the wolf
of wenefeld was the lord of inner fell
and the head of house stark during the
targaryen civil war
upon the death of king viserys the first
targaryen rhaenyra's son prince jacary's
valerian flew to winterfell on his
dragon vermex
to gain the support of the starks and
the north for his mother rhaenyra
targaryen's claim to the iron throne
the alliance known as the pact of ice
and fire stated that a targaryen
princess the future first-born daughter
of jacarys would marry his son rickon
kragen pledged his support to the blacks
during the dance of the dragons
after prince jacary's valerian secured
the allegiance of the north for his
mother rhaenyra targaryen
lord craig and stark sent two thousand
soldiers known as the winter wolves
south
commanded by his bannerman lord rodrick
dustin known as roddy de roy to support
the queen's claim
while he remained in the north to gather
his own banners
due to the vastness of the north this
would take long
rainer was killed at dragonstone by king
aegon the second targaryen however but
kragen with his army still marched south
nonetheless in support of her son
prince aegon the younger the war
continued between the supporters of the
dead queen
and the king's remaining loyalists
riverlands the north and the vale still
supported the claim of rhaenyra's son
egg on the third
valegan ii only had the stormlands army
able to defend him
the lord stark moved south with his army
toward throwage on the second and placed
rhaenyra's son on the armed throne
lord boros baratheon was marching north
with his own banners
but he was defeated on the king's road
by the riverlords known as the lads
before lord stark arrived having failed
to get the battle he wanted stark
nevertheless wanted to punish those who
had supported aegon ii
he moved his forces to claim king's
landing where he found that hagon ii
had been poisoned and dagon iii was now
a king
since he was aged 11 a regency needed to
be established
and several lords were vying for power
with his formidable presence and
character as well as with his army lord
stark was the most powerful man in
king's landing
with his newfound power lord stark
wanted to punish those who had supported
aegon ii
such as the baratheons the lannisters
and the hightowers
however lord corliss valerian had
already sent envoys to old town
storm's end and casterly rock to make
peace
while the word of the end voice was
being waited upon there was another
matter that lord stark wanted to deal
with
the assassination of aegon ii while he
had believed that he had been a usurper
and had been riding south to oust him
from power
lord stark did not believe in killing
him but rather in defeating him on the
field of battle
he declared that all those who had
partaken in the killing needed to be
punished
his troops arrested several people in
the capital
including lord valerian lord larry
strong the master of whispers
and several members of the kingsguard
after these arrests were made lord stark
was appointed hand of the king by king
aegon iii
during the day that followed his
appointment lord stark led
the trials and execution of the traitors
sending mouse to the wall and executing
a member of the king's guard
and lord strong who refused to take the
black following the traditions of house
stark lord kragen beheaded them both
himself with ice
the valyrian still great sword of the
starks this event came to be known as
the hour of the wolf
or the judgment of the wolf lord
valerian escaped execution or sentence
when the king
issued an edict that he was to be spared
and returned to his former dignity as
lord of the tides
creighton married elise in blackwood in
exchange for honoring aegon the third's
pardon of lord corliss
lord stark resigned as the hand the
following day
and left king's landing for winterfell
the snobs are falling in the north and
my place is at winterfell
said kragen explaining why he cannot
stay at king's landing
it was during regan's long reign as lord
of winner felt that house stark's
loyalty to the iron throne
doubtful at best prior to this became a
certainty neither rhaenyra and her
blacks
reagan ii and his greens are remembered
well in the history of the westeros
and many argue that neither side truly
won at the end
but it's a fact that rainer's loyalists
won the war and rhaenyra's children got
the throne
let me know your thoughts about
everything the prequel its characters
especially the blacks in the comment
section down below
also let me know which side you support
in this targaryen civil war
the blacks or the greens and why thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this video please give it a big thumbs
up and i hope to see you in the next one
peace
you